this is my Scott base haircut this is a  new one for me I can see I've got my  haircut in it in Antarctica bobble chuck  if I have butcher that's a carpenter any  time you got one on and it's only got  one eyes it's the good half line here we  go  in all seriousness  thank you for cutting it that's all yeah  my wife usually cuts my hair just the  first time I've ever had a butcher cut  my name  you really are trained as a butcher yep  trust in the butcher it's a good story  don't actually not a little Sadie's but  a lot of credit there you go they make a  good cameraman yeah I'm saying yes I can  tell by the movement never thought I'd  be looking out at the Ross Ice Shelf we  need an air bag man Harris and the  Cummins and gals on the bikes that's  right how do you like that it's very  authentic yeah  first and type I and type the Q caption  all right that's right all right let's  see how he did thank you Thanks